now today we're canceling not for the
first time probably not the last
cosmopolitan magazine in fairness
um they could be canceled for literally
everything that's ever been printed in
the pages of their godforsaken
publication but this month's issue
i think warrants a special mention on
the cover is featured in obese woman
smiling proudly with the words this is
healthy
printed across now notice
i want you to notice this how the body
positivity movement
has slid inexorably down the predictable
slippery slope because five years ago
this cover would have looked similar and
had a similar message but instead it
would have said something like
this is beautiful now it was wrong to
call obesity beautiful
but at least you could argue wrongly in
my view but at least plausibly
that beauty is subjective you know and
so you know you can call anything
beautiful
and the benefit for those promoting the
message five years ago was that most
people are too afraid to object
thinking that if they argue that obesity
isn't beautiful
it would be the same as saying that all
fat people are ugly
of course it's not the same it is
possible to make the case
that obesity isn't beautiful which it
isn't
without calling all fat people ugly in
the same way that you can make the case
that alcoholism isn't beautiful which it
isn't
without calling all alcoholics ugly it's
not the same thing
saying alcoholism isn't beautiful is not
the same thing as saying
you're ugly because you're an alcoholic
two different things
but we've graduated beyond potentially
subjective words like beautiful
and now we're being told that obesity is
actually healthy
and this is the way it always goes this
is always the trajectory
you know the slippery slope is real and
we're on about a thousand different ones
in this culture
so we start by you know the left starts
by demanding that you accept a false but
relatively innocuous or seemingly
well-intentioned premise like
obesity is beautiful and once your mind
has been properly conditioned
they move to the radical and dangerous
conclusion
that was always embedded in the original
premise
which now is obesity is healthy so let's
read a little bit from this cosmo
article it says um
it says influencer cali thorpe is one of
social media's best-known advocates of
self-love in 2016
she launched the community page called
the confidence corner on instagram to
spread positivity to her 250 000
followers
but it really all started with a diet
blog in 2012.
quote i thought if i made myself
accountable to strangers i'd lose weight
it made me feel worse than ever she adds
i had a really terrible relationship
with my body growing up i was always
i always struggled with the fact that it
was different to my friends
i tried every single diet by the way
sidebar here
most of the time when people say they
tried every diet the problem is
precisely that they're just
trying the diet they do it for a few
days or a few weeks and they quit
they're dipping their toes into
different diet fads but they give up as
soon as it becomes difficult
the fact is that almost everyone who
says they have they've tried really hard
to lose weight
but haven't uh haven't been able to
in almost all cases they actually
haven't tried hard at all
they may have tried momentarily but not
long enough and not consistent enough
that's a simple reality the idea that it
somehow
doesn't work to eat healthy you know
that lots of people would still be
morbidly obese
even after radically altering their diet
and lifestyle to make it more healthy
is just absurd but getting back to the
article it says
these days cali adheres to the body
neutrality
movement which focuses on what your body
can do rather than how it looks
plus size people often feel like they
can't be part of the wellness space
we're trolled for being fat then then
can feel excluded from exercise because
our bodies don't fit the narrative
first of all you're not being ex nobody
can be excluded from exercise
if you want to just lay down on your on
your uh
carpet and do some crunches that's you
can't be excluded from doing that
but i mean that that's one excuse to not
exercise i guess
you know i was going to go jogging today
but i've been they excluded me
i got excluded from jogging i can't
and from there the article goes on to
chronicle the stories of various other
women some of whom are in fine shape
others who are
also morbidly obese the message is that
they've all learned to love their bodies
and that all of their body types are
healthy
not surprisingly no attempt is made to
scientifically or logically defend the
proposition that obesity is healthy
it's merely asserted with an exclamation
point
and were meant to accept it at face
value
the only defense is as always an
emotional one
the argument seems to be that obesity is
healthy
because it makes fat people feel bad
when you say obesity is
not healthy this is similar to the
argument that a man is a woman because
it makes him feel bad when you say he's
not a woman
the irony is that the phrase body
acceptance is used in this article
referring to a woman named jessamine
stanley also obese it says quote
the journey to body acceptance is
something that has taken her a long time
that being jessamine quote body shaming
was one of the first things i learned to
do i grew up in a community where all of
my physical attributes wide nose big
belly big ass
big lips dark skin were deemed ugly
now first of all these things are not
all the same okay
one of these things is not like the
others right the size of your nose your
lips
so the the color of your skin these
cannot be naturally changed and they
shouldn't be unnaturally changed either
in my opinion
but the size of your belly can be
changed
and given that an overly bulbous belly
is hazardous to your physical well-being
you should change it just because there
are some things about yourself
that you should proudly embrace like
your skin color your nose size
that doesn't mean that all things about
you should be proudly embraced
but going back to the body acceptance
phrase
it strikes me that this is exactly what
the body acceptance movement is not
doing body acceptance is what they are
opposing
not what they're promoting you haven't
accepted something if you refuse to
acknowledge the full reality of it
an addict hasn't reached the stage of
acceptance if he's still claiming that
he doesn't that he doesn't have a
problem
you aren't accepting your obese body if
you're insisting that it's healthy and
wonderful
that's denial not acceptance it's the
opposite
yes obese people should accept
that they are obese and then they should
work to change it
because it could very likely kill them
if they don't
that's what acceptance looks like and
this obesity is healthy stuff takes on
an even more sinister tone when you
consider the timing
covid is still surging out there and
it's well known that the obese are
especially vulnerable to it
so you're already more likely to die of
heart disease and dozens of other
complications
uh due to obesity and covet adds just
yet another danger on top of that
cosmo wants you to embrace that danger
cosmo wants you to be a martyr for body
acceptance
he wants you to love your obesity so
much
that you allow it to kill you and that's
insane
and for that cosmo is canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content